it's like the best work she's ever done
like she looks amazing
hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's her name my name is Norville -
Floyd nor velchev Floyd is here with me
today guys you should check out
Norville's channel NJC productions he is
a filmmaker a male model ass model as
well I'm telling you this guy's got the
buns of Man of Steel ain't that right
buddy it's an acquired taste you know
yes and well we're gonna watch the day a
trailer for a movie that a lot of people
have been asking me to check out for a
while it's called destroyer
it's from director Karyn Kusama who did
a movie that I absolutely adore if you
guys haven't seen it's called the
invitation I think it's on Netflix
they'll go watch it and you've seen
Jennifer's Body yes that was one of the
very first movies that introduced me to
Megan Fox
besides transformers that was one of the
very first movies I've ever seen
watching movie the first 20 years of my
life and I like creepy yet sexy at the
same time nice that's what people say
about me
all right well and by the way he has a
trailer for a feature film he actually
directed a horror I keep want to say
short film but it's not it's a feature
feature called Beyond deceive that's
gotten a lot of great feedback we even
did a trailer reaction you guys can go
check that out so you can find that
trailer NJC productions channel anyway
let's get into this go into it yes I
believe this movie stars Tom Cruise's
ex-wife Katie Rogers Rogers yeah
[Laughter]
whose paper all my scrapping jealous
hungry scared I'm gonna find something
Jason something
okay
you can be better than me
[Music]
[Laughter]
who is it you know I do you know I do
[Music]
and that you're all start placing our
agent undercover she'll look right
enough next to our guy
we do this we accept the company
Sebastian Stan winter soldier
you chose to play cops and robbers
[Music]
and you lost
[Music]
my Chi Oscar performance my man to start
getting my cry
I have strongest nipple chills
[Music]
oh dude
[Music]
I like that's why hey that's my kind of
movies I'm getting strong Awards
contender on that one just from the
trail alone oh yeah in particular I mean
yeah it's a December movie as well
and those are usually when they believe
there's so much goodness in this trailer
so much greatness here I love the score
that they put in the trailer yeah things
like like gritty and trailers is like
the music that they choose give you like
the total with the movie and that one
was it was great I actually felt yeah
exactly I wouldn't be surprised if that
was the music in the actual movie
because the invitation I don't know if
it's the same composer or whatever but
the invitation has some amazing composed
music in that film this kind of eerie
haunting sort of music I really loved
and just looking at the imagery here
I love the tones of I'm kind of drawn to
these like darker films like it's
awfully gonna be a slow burn exactly I
could totally tell be a slow burn
exactly I know some people aren't
necessarily fans of these like artistic
slow burn time yeah like Mandy or like
another movie that absolutely like
hereditary yeah like those type of
movies but I absolutely love them and I
appreciate them those are some of my
favorites go watch your infinity wars
and your Deadpool's okay only cool
people like Norville and I watch real
movies yeah we're the real film yeah
critics I've seen Pulp Fiction so many
times I've seen it twice I know so much
about film my god Citizen Kane and the
best movie ever I actually haven't seen
Citizen Kane double you know okay but
there are like the tones and the vibes
of this sort of isolation and
desperation like when they're in the
snow at the beginning and she's holding
her daughter I love also gravitated to
like launching isolated vibes yeah I
think we're trailers like this what can
be very misleading often this is I
imagine this movie
we'll have a sort of build up like it'll
probably be like you said a slow burn
and then as it keeps going up probably
escalate into some crazy terrible it'll
probably be like the most boring movie
ever that's a great ending that all of a
sudden the whole movies yeah movies
great imagine this isn't movie require
for a patient viewer so when you see
images in here of like wielding the guns
and I'm like that's barely gonna be in
the film
the thing is they tend to throw those
images in here because they're trying to
sell and whatever but if you really
dissect the moments you see [ __ ] like
that I imagine that they'll probably be
more violence and there is action if
that makes any sense giving like a
female John with violin that one part
okay with that right that's not gonna be
the probably and the cool kid yeah
that's about it people get puncher I
imagine there'll be some like bloody
moments but I don't think it's gonna be
like full-on action sequences the IMDB
description has it saying because I
wasn't entirely clear on what the plot
was a police detective reconnects to
people from an undercover assignment and
her distant past in order to make peace
I'm kind of glad we read that because
it's like the horror elements it doesn't
feel like a horror film it kind of feels
like that's an underlying tone is horror
yeah where this is a crime drama like
it's more of a thriller
yeah not horror yeah I don't see any
scary images other than the cold
continues because you went all Charlize
Theron monster on yeah no I think she'll
probably do a great job but it looks
like a character piece of character
study of her so I get why a lot of the
critics that are flashing things on
there are all about Nicole Kidman's
performance and it does look like a
transformative performance it doesn't
look like this give me an Oscar type of
thing you know like hyper expressive and
stuff and a lot of yelling and
everything yeah looks like a lot of
subtle it said give me enough is you
know I hope she'll at least get
recognized in some way for a fast one
for it yeah I mean I haven't seen the
movie so I mean once the movie comes out
we'll know but off of the trailer
because they have trailer Awards
you know like best trailer or blah blah
so if there was category for the Best
Actress in the trailer
and I love how Sebastian stands doing
these things where he's like the main
male supporting characters oh yeah what
feels he was a knight Anya he's like hey
soldier yeah I like to be the support
all that you'll see him in the Winter
Soldier and then the other movies he's
in he's like the dick guy yeah and he's
probably the guy in this one something
tells me she's gonna die by the end of
this I imagine there's some sort of like
redemption tale that we're getting here
yeah yeah maybe but man it's been like a
crazy year for like strong female
performances this year like a lot more
vel sexist if you can't think of any
yeah I destroy her no um hereditary came
out this year right all right it's aria
that was a great one now that remember
that movie let's give it to her instead
of Nicole Caen well they're like during
that one I just thought bad times at the
El Royale
Cynthia Reva I liked it you said the
areevo is fantastic in that film -
there's no there's so many good
performances Lady Gaga and a star was
born I think there's gonna be I love
that that was your authentic white boy
no the girl that I took with to go see
that movie she cried I didn't cry but
let's just say great gatsby the world of
the Caprio is my third favorite movie
stars where's my favorite movie of the
year
stars stars born stars born I think Star
Wars I'm like that has nothing to do
[Music]
this looks like my exact kind of movie
million the slow burn with great
performances and beautiful score like
here's what makes or breaks movie for me
is the score like I downloaded the score
for Mandy I downloaded the score of
Blade Runner
20:49 which is my number one favorite
movie and I also downloaded the score
for Batman V Superman I'll tell you this
much the Batman V Superman did not have
that score I would not have liked it as
much as I did
fair completely agree with you yeah
let's hope this music is actually in the
movie alright guys well thanks for
watching
are you excited for destroyer I am you
know it's not being destroyed isn't it
cool Kidman's critter people that's why
it's a fan of the channel I just gonna
radiate a calm I'll write a comedy right
there great joke listen subscribe leave
a comment down below tell us how you
thought about the video acknowledged in
bells yes engines I hope you caught all
that see you guys